welcome to CBS this morning more than 55
million Americans will be on the move
this week but a storm in the West is
threatening to bring travel misery too
many winter storm alerts stretch from
the Rockies to the Upper Midwest some
areas expect a foot of snow Travel could
be especially difficult on Wednesday
that's the day before Thanksgiving and a
second storm is expected to cause
trouble later in the holiday weekend CBS
News climate and weather contributor
Jeff Baird Ellie is with us Jeff good
morning how are things looking right now
a lot of frustrated people I think
that's my prediction for the upcoming
week it is going to be a tough travel
week unfortunately so this is the setup
right now big dip in the Jetstream cold
air pouring south from Canada the one
bit of good news big high pressure
across the southeast mild and protected
there so that's the best area this week
as we look ahead storm forms later
tonight and tomorrow morning around
Denver heavy snow blizzard conditions
gusts over 40 miles an hour moves
through the plains states towards
Minneapolis the good news is it's rain
in Chicago but still going to cause some
issues there Detroit and Cleveland heavy
snow on the northern side of the system
as it moves through the plane today's
how much snow generally about 6 to 12
inches of snow is likely as the system
makes its way across and I do think
we're gonna see probably as much as a
foot plus in places like the Rockies you
can see that snow swath right there the
purple indicating the heaviest snow wind
is going to be a very big issue as it
moves across the country it's going to
move across the Great Lakes probably
gusting to 40 50 miles an hour at times
and then eventually it will end up right
around the New York City area and when
it does we are concerned that the
balloons may very well be grounded on
Thanksgiving morning that turkey is very
concerned you can see the look in his
face because it'll be the first time
since 1971 the kids would not be happy
say it ain't so Jeff well that's an
unhappy looking turkey all right